una estudiante cuelga bloques de masas
diferentes de una polea de masa m y
radio r y los libera a partir del reposo
el estudiante mide el tiempo de caída t
y la magnitud de la velocidad angular o
mega cuando el bloque alcanza una
distancia de por debajo del eje existe
una fricción considerable entre el eje y
la polea cuál de los siguientes
diagramas puede mostrar las medidas que
tomó el estudiante como una función de
la torca aplicada a la polea pausa en el
vídeo y traten de pensar en esto por su
cuenta primero tenemos que comprender a
qué se refieren
estos diagramas y también veremos qué es
lo que sucede con este sistema de masa y
polea el eje horizontal de estos
diagramas se refiere a la torca aplicada
en donde se encuentra dicha tuerca
aplicada en este sistema pues aquí
tenemos esta masa que suponemos se
encuentra en un planeta como la tierra
por lo que la gravedad está jalando
hacia abajo esta masa aquí está la
fuerza del peso de este objeto que jala
hacia abajo recordemos que la polea
tiene un radio r por lo que esta fuerza
multiplicada por este radio nos va a dar
la torca aplicada
y obviamente mientras más grande sea la
masa que haya aquí habrá un mayor peso y
eso nos dará más torque este eje
horizontal muestra que conforme se
agreguen masas más grandes aquí va a
haber una torta cada vez más grande
ahora en el eje vertical tenemos omega
sub
efe / / t es decir que tenemos la
velocidad angular final ya que la masa
ha recorrido la distancia de dividida
entre el tiempo que le llevó recorrer
esa distancia si suponemos que todo el
sistema comienza estando en reposo
podemos ver esto como la aceleración
angular esta es la aceleración angular
como función de la torca aplicada
escribimos la aceleración angular en
cada uno de estos ejes aunque es más
preciso decir que es la aceleración
angular promedio durante este periodo de
tiempo desde que comenzamos hasta el
tiempo t que es lo que pasa en este
sistema cuando tenemos más pequeñas
tendremos una tuerca pequeña pero si hay
una fricción considerable que es lo que
nos dicen en el enunciado existe una
fricción considerable entre el eje y la
polea así que para masas pequeñas
cerca no será lo suficientemente grande
para superar la fricción lo cual va a
ocasionar que no haya aceleración
angular en estos casos todo permanecerá
en reposo pero al agregar más masa aquí
llegará un momento en el que la torca
será lo suficientemente grande como para
superar la fricción entre el eje y la
polea ahora veamos cuál de estos
diagramas describe lo que acabamos de
analizar el diagrama describe un
escenario donde poca torca aplicada
genera una gran aceleración angular lo
que no tiene sentido así que descartamos
esta opción
el diagrama se muestra una aceleración
angular que es más o menos constante y
que es independiente de la torca
aplicada lo que tampoco coincide con lo
que analizamos recuerden que mientras
más masa hay aquí mayor será la
aceleración angular así que también
descartamos esta opción los diagramas b
y d muestran una tendencia de incremento
en la aceleración angular es decir
mientras más torca aplicada hay más se
incrementa la aceleración angular cuál
de estos diagramas se elegirían ustedes
si vemos el diagrama de nos sugiere que
tan pronto como se tiene una tuerca
comienza a incrementar la aceleración
angular y esto sucedería si este sistema
no tuviera fricción o si la fricción no
fuera muy pequeña pero como vimos al
analizar el sistema para masas pequeñas
que generan poco peso y por lo tanto
generan poca torca ésta no podrá superar
la fricción y no habrá aceleración
angular para tuercas pequeñas pero
conforme aumenta la torca entonces podrá
superar la fricción y el sistema
comenzará a acelerar elegimos la opción
b con esto terminamos y nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo